serious crisis at home serious crisis
abroad biden's first year at the white
house has been an abject failure and
yesterday's train wreck marathon press
conference only made everything worse
just look at the cover of the new york
post headline reads he said what biden's
confused disastrous q a well now we know
why they've been hiding him away at
pretty much every occasion this press
conference was so bad white house press
secretary and propagandist jensaki had
to circle back and was forced to issue
not one but two very lengthy statements
clarifying biden's remarks oh he really
meant to say this
including the president's truly inept
comments surrounding ukraine that
shocked the world that's because in
between the lying and the rage and the
bizarre whispering just get vaccinated
you know and the bouts of confusion joe
biden all but invited vladimir putin
gave a green light to him for him to
attack ukraine so long it was a quote
minor incursion the russians are testing
us joe biden failed that test needless
to say the people of ukraine are now
very very concerned rightly so
they watch those remarks i think i think
with horror one uh ukrainian official
who i've been in close contact with
while this marathon press conference is
underway said that he was you know i'm
quoting here shocked
that president biden would give a green
light to vladimir putin in this way the
big concern of course which is what he
was alluding to is that it gives putin
and this is another quote from it so it
gives the green light to putin to enter
ukraine at his pleasure and that's not
just one ukrainian official other
ukraine officials have responded in a
similar way
today's ukraine president also issued a
response tweeting quote we want to
remind the great powers there are no
minor incursions and small nations just
as there are no minor casualties and
little grief from the loss of loved ones
no matter what you think about russia's
looming invasion keep this in mind
president trump was impeached by
democrats accused of being a russian
plant that was totally a lie for three
years planted by oh hillary clinton's
dirty misinformation russian dossier
then of course we had the issue of the
routine phone call with the president of
ukraine joe biden has now essentially
invited vladimir putin to invade ukraine
democrats they could care less the mob
the media can care less joe biden
literally giving putin a waiver to build
a pipeline simultaneously he's firing
thousands of american workers on the
keystone xl pipeline high paying career
jobs zero experience hunter makes
millions from russia from an oligarch a
pro-putin ukrainian oligarch as vice
president joe leveraged the billion of
your tax dollars had a prosecutor fired
in ukraine for investigating his crack
addicted son being paid millions with no
experience uh think about that does none
of this seem strange to you let's ask
the question what if his last name was
trump and still biden's presser was so
terrible in many ways that some in the
media mob they couldn't even hide their
shock and horror take a look
it was a terrible moment in the press
conference uh when when he talked about
a minor incursion there is no minor
incursion at the end of the press
conference if you have to put a
statement out to try to clean up what
happened in the press conference uh
that's not never a good thing i think
it's to have to be honest that you can
be a
foggy meandering a president say like
reagan near the end if you're winning
but if you're foggy and meandering on
key questions and you're also not
winning
uh then you've got a real problem
yeah
let there be no mistake he's no ronald
reagan now in fairness to joe there was
at least one person that apparently
loved his performance the number one
chief conspiracy theorist in all america
rachel maddow claiming biden held a
lengthy press conference to show off his
tremendous stamina in fl in front of
vladimir putin oh okay now of course
that stamina completely evaporated today
as he tried to avoid and ignore any and
all tough questions surrounding his
blunder with putin and ukraine take a
look
that was a question from our very own
fox news correspondent jackie heinrich
and according to obama's director of
global engagement quote it isn't a
stupid question it's a really important
one we continue to allow putin to set
the terms timeline and trajectory of the
of this crisis it's time we stop being
so reactive and start creating some of
our own conditions now if joe biden
actually wants to see something really
stupid he might want to look in the
mirror because according to his own
colleagues joe was allegedly considered
one of the dumbest u.s senators in
congress and now his steep cognitive
decline is only making that matter
really worse in fact today for the
second time he could not even remember
the name of his own infrastructure czar
uh take a look at this embarrassing
typical moment
so thank you very much and i'm going to
turn it over to
the
the guy who i asked to
come out of retirement not my retirement
but coming
take over his gigantic job for me
mr president thank you so much i'm
honored
this guy that that guy has a name it's
mitch landrieu joey and remember the
last time you called the mitch mcconnell
by mistake at this point is anyone in
this country surprised that joe's poll
numbers are in the gutter 33 quinnipiac
just today a new low in the ap survey a
vast majority disapprove of his job as
president only 28 percent of the
american people want this guy to run for
reelection it's that bad according to
trafalgar that's robert haley
republicans now have a 13-point
advantage on the generic ballot they
started 2021 at a nine point deficit now
in an effort to boost his poll numbers
the biden administration is trying out
someone even more unpopular than joe his
vice president kamala harris this
morning she participated in a handful of
televised interviews not one of them
went well and during a tense interview
on nbc not exactly the hardest hitting
news in the world harris forcefully had
to remind savannah guthrie that she is
the vice president of the united states
and deserves respect take a look
ukrainian officials reportedly heard
these words from president biden with
alarm
i know the white house tried to clarify
it and clean it up afterwards but
was the damage done you can't unring the
bell is vladimir putin likely to listen
to a later statement from the white
house press secretary or the words of
president biden
i will repeat myself
and i'm vice president of the united
states and the president and i
work closely together and i know his
position because he has been consistent
in that regard
almost sounds like al franken on
saturday night live tonight it's clear
we have a president and vice president
they are not up to this job but i know
this and you know this america's enemies
they're also seeing everything we're
seeing and sadly tonight as a result the
world and our country is less safe and
it is less secure hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else